today I'm super excited because my best
friend and fellow 25 year old from
college Kate finally save enough money
to come visit me
she's a lyft driver and a part-time
stand-up and she's pretty funny
I almost got hit by a Bentley on my way
here
maybe next time hey they're expensive
are you guys oh wait that's where she's
funny well she's really different a
trick I use your bathroom real quick
it's fall oh no he went skateboarding
don't get to see each other often but
when we do it's like we're 20 again mama
do you really think these fake IDs for
work
definitely plus we all luck over 21 oh
this will be fun to watch good what's
going on been letting underage girls in
wishing for the best go one God he's
taking forever
this sucks just seriously oh poor Henry
he's all by himself tonight
poor guy it's about time what
get you guys cosmos hey hey for the way
you guys
oh here what you do not even apologize
okay just this outfit look okay oh yeah
so cute
yeah what good women this is a shirt oh
look at em they are some beautiful man
look at these d-bag holders hmm the ones
haircut is controlling her baby oh my
gos it has text before you going with it
yeah oh oh oh this one's gonna go see hi
but he's gay he's gay he's gay
Hey gosh go how'd it go it was amazing
she says not looking for anything right
now but he invited us all to go out rock
climbing with him and his friend
tomorrow
oh so adventurous yeah oh you're gonna
make such a cute couple when they come
out reminds me of my first boyfriend
remember Jeff oh yeah remember he's
pathetic major Brian Matthew Stephen
Reed manchego swiss baby my bio class is
so done it's like I'm not gonna be a
biologist I'm going into advertising
like Mad Men well gosh my mom is so
annoying
moms are crazy she's calling me now as a
mom doing
oh and I need viruses on Netflix
password oh you can use oh thank you
well you got my mom's 30 is technically
still so young you're right 30 is just
too old though screaming all right let's
close up I gotta work in I am keep the
check Henry thank you honestly
Oh Oh